Go pull up Gaming for Hope. Go pull up some body cam footage.
Go pull up the boring useless that your audience loves all the
slop and just pour the slop out. Okay, put the slop in the bag,
little bro. Just be the whole man. If you're going to be a be
the whole and ignore the situation. I just want you to have enough
of a spine to shut your stupid mouth.
I caught a clip from Chud here. Hold on.
>> He sent me a clip from Chud and I do want to talk about
it cuz it's I just don't get why
I don't get what Chud's doing when he even talks about this stuff
to be honest with you. Like it just seems very very very goofy
to me. So I'm basically just thinking about his comments on the
reporting stuff.
And I just think it's very very very silly to be honest with
you. I totally I I'm totally fine if Chud wants to distance.
I understand that. Like not wanting to participate. I think it's
like bad. I think you should probably when you see like something
that's quite bad happening to other people, something that basically
affects your line of work. Like if you're a if you're like a
blacksmith and you notice like the mobs going and or like like
some group of other blacksmiths are going like intimidating other
people and they're giving them part of their profits, right?
If you never stand up for that, you're just just go give them
your profits right away, right?
You know what I you know what I mean? Like it's if you don't
care if you're not going to do anything about it, then I guess
just like accept that reality and then move on.
Or you know, in this case for Chud, like just go start doing
your other content. But I don't understand why he keeps reviewing
stuff from this sphere and from this like situation and then
commenting and going, "But I don't really want to be a part of
it or I don't really want to talk about it." Actually, what I
really want to talk about is
like how weird it is for these people to call for reports at
all. Let's let's take a look. That's what he was annoyed with
me.
>> He's talking about me. me. He's talking about women.
But, um, I don't know, man. I just I just think there are some
things he's done. Um, Chud is obsessed with optics. No, he's
not. No, he's not. Optics is a way to just like fudge and muddy
the waters and never take an actual position on things. He's
not like obsessed with optics. He just wants to make his money,
which is fine, but then don't talk [__] about the
people who are trying to like actually take a position. Is all
I would say, right?
Like if you're going to be and like calling him spineless, it's
Well, I actually hadn't called him spineless yet. He is spineless.
But, calling him spineless is not really an indictment of him.
Like if I had kids and I was like, you know, getting a house,
I would probably be spineless,
Right? He's got like a lot of things going on that make it so
he would be
And so, I get it, but I just don't get the consistent hand-wringing.
Like it's quite frustrating, the consistent hand-wringing over
like my actions or Acandros's actions. Like this stuff over and
over and over again. Why are you focusing on that? To me, it's
very clear what you're trying to do. So, I'm get I'm actually
helping Chud here, okay? So, I'm going to talk a lot of [__]
about Chud.
And I'm going to help him, cuz what he wants is distance from
me and like me saying I reported Destiny, right? I'm just just
going to help him and point out that he's like obviously just
self-interested and trying to pretend there's some actual analysis
there, but there isn't. He's like, "I'm not sure if it's coping.
I'm not sure if it's real." Right? But, he's trying to pretend
there's some analysis there. There's no analysis going on. He's
just transparently scared, which is fine. Just say you're scared.
Right? Don't come and say like, "Oh, it's it's actually totally
wrong for you to do this." No, it's not.
No, it's not.
Like actually just either either give some real analysis
or [__] off. Take Take the Pisco pill, right? And
just leave the space. Don't talk about this [__]
at all, because you don't want to be involved. Don't take potshots
at the people you know like
Hoping that it gets you further out of the situation you can
kind of just fire potshots off. Very cowardly, very weird behavior,
in my opinion. Okay? Right? But from there we get into this Dickers
and and Aiden debate. And he starts like hand-wringing again.
Dude, actually just go and watch something else. Go pull up Gaming
for Hope. Go pull up some body cam footage. Go pull up the boring,
useless [__] that your audience loves. All the slop
and just pour the slop out. Okay? Put the slop in the bag, little
bro. Don't try to do analysis on this [__] if you're
too scared to comment. >> done. Sure.
They're just trying to isolate Jstark because he reported Destiny
for the endless barrage of doxing. Yeah, I don't know. I just
think you know, participating in any sort of reporting or talking
about reporting. If you think someone's broken the rules, you
have to report their channel. And like leave it at that. I think
you're you know, open yourself
Uh so there's a just total disconnect from actual like deeper
analysis there.
So he he says that he thinks there's just some doxing that happened.
He doesn't know the context of this. And he he's basically trying
to argue that no matter the context, it wouldn't matter. And
obviously if I put him in the same context, I'm pretty confident
Chud would say, "Oh, like no, I would have to do something more."
But we'll keep watching.
>> trying to get other people to do it, you know, like
just go and do it yourself. Right? I mean, you know, if someone
is genuinely doing something that you think is wrong, there's
nothing wrong with using the reporting tools
But when you talk about it, it's just you know, I mean, I don't
know. I've not seen the evidence, but what's the line between
talking about it and mass reporting? And I just got I've got
a phone Oh, I literally had like a guide for how to do it. It's
a very complex report to do. I had like a guide for how to do
it, to report him. Well, I think I think technically somebody
else had it, but
I can totally defend that and I will defend that. >> well,
I wouldn't like, you know, I wouldn't like cut someone off from
mass reporting necessarily. I don't think that's like a hardline
for me. But I certainly would be less, you know,
amicable with them. Let's put it that way. I wouldn't want to
like knock about with them because it's like like, why are you
doing that? It's like it's like a bad look on you, if if you
like. Do you know what I mean by that? I I don't see why. It's
not a bad look on you at all. It's not a bad look on you at all,
so long as you can explain it and want to look into it. You are
too scared because your platforms are gone. So, you're saying
things instead of saying, "I'm too scared to go further into
this because I don't want to get my channel
Which is the answer. You just do some like surface level analysis.
This kind of looks bad. This kind of looks bad. That's all we're
going to hear as I go through this. This kind of looks bad. It
creates a risk for my channel, right? This kind of looks bad.
It creates a risk for my channel. Does he know the deeper context
on any of this? Has he tried to look into it? Or is he just like,
"Oh, I'm just going to do some surface level like analysis, look
at the way Dan frames things, and then go, 'Oh, this is like
really bad. I I totally disavow this.'"
It's understandable. I That's what I said at the beginning. It's
totally understandable why he's scared. I have no problem with
him scared. I have no problem with him at all being scared. What
I have a problem with is him going and basically helping the
people who are doing the actual bad behavior by perpetuating
this narrative that there was something wrong with doing the
reports.
That's all I'm asking is instead of just be the whole [__]
man. If you're going to be a [__] be the whole [__]
and ignore the situation.
That's all. That's all I'm asking for. Right? If you're going
to prostrate yourself like this, which I understand.
I understand that what it looks like is we're like the the truck
is Sorry, we're the like the guy with the briefcase in Tiananmen
Square or something, right? Like you are totally I get that you
don't want to go stand next to that guy. That makes total sense
to me. But, just say, "Hey, I don't want to be anywhere near
that. I don't want to do That's fine.
But, don't say like the principle of standing there is wrong.
Principally you should never stand there. Principally that it
can never happen ever.
Cuz that's wrong.
At worst at worst the only criticism you could have here is that
I basically explained to people how to do this report in a space
with other creators who could be put at risk. That is it.
That is it. That's all. And also don't forget I'm still being
like very calm with this. This is all to help Chud. Cuz now Chud
can go and react to this and and I can have attacked him over
it and we could be totally disconnected, right? So all of the
comments about his spinelessness and That's that's all helping
him.
Helping him disconnect. And again, I should reiterate he's not
spineless because he's worried about his channel. That's not
spineless. He's got other other things going on with his life
that he needs to make sure are taken care of,
The spineless thing is like helping the other group by making
it seem like I'm the person who did something wrong or Nek Andros
is the person who did something wrong because you're scared of
That's all. You're like you're basically enabling them in their
behavior.
It's like I don't want to you know that's not my
That's not me. I don't want to do that
And I just think J Stov and Nek Andros I just think they're like
terrible at dealing with this [__] Like they get
involved in these like high pressure dynamics and fights. And
they're just [__] at dealing with it and they're
terrible at
Uh again, I had not really been covering Destiny that much like
almost at all. I think I had been doing like the conservative
civil war was like the the GOP civil war. I was doing like all
politics content content. I was not covering Destiny at all.
Right? And then he started threatening people. Started threatening
to dox people, right? And then he started doxing people.
And then once he made it clear that not only so I should have
put this. I have the most important things on my side
Okay? And that's the facts. The facts are on my side. Destiny
admitted,
okay, he admitted he did this and he stated like actual malice
in doing it. I am doing this, I'm going to go after these people.
I if he he gave warnings about doxxing and then he followed through
on the doxxing like on the doxxing attempts that he said he was
going to, right? Actual malice. Actually has acknowledged that
he has doxxed people multiple times. So, he's done it intentionally,
repeatedly.
And these are objective and self-evident violations.
They're not things that are subjective and that's a big deal
because if you're trying to call for mass reports on any subjective
standard, that creates like a a deception on your part,
But we're not doing it on a subjective standard, we're doing
it on an objective like piece of evidence, right? Destiny has
himself said it happened. Oh, wasn't DGG? Yeah, they were. They
were. They were. But
so leave alone the fact that Destiny has called to mass report
me before this, right? Leave alone that cuz I'm not going to
say an eye for eye is appropriate. But I will say that it is
absolutely appropriate to take this course of action in this
situation. To get other people to help do this complex report
on his channel because he is using his channel to continue to
exert
and basically spread this message and call for more doxx and
call for more people to be harassed.
Right? That like that is Listen, that's um those are smaller
things. But once he got to the point where he stated that he
had the actual intent to quit my community, to make people leave
by doxxing people in the community, absolutely I was within my
rights to do this. To create a guide on how to report him and
give like links to all of the specific like PII leaks he had
done. Right? So,
again, we have basically everything you need to prove something
happened.
And then he basically is going to argue that mass reporting is
wrong, right? Why is mass reporting wrong?
I guess I can think of two reasons mass reporting is wrong, okay?
One is you're reporting somebody on a subjective standard and
you're trying to in- indicate to the people who review those
reports that it's so past the subjective standard that they don't
really think much about whether or not they want to take action,
right? Or you're working on some subje- subjective standard like
a slur or like some hate speech thing and as additional reports
come in you create you increase the chance that some random like
support staff will flag the
But this is not either of those situations, okay? It's not either
of those situations. So I don't think that anybody can really
argue that the mass reporting is bad outside of that it could
have negative consequences for the people around me, but guess
what?
There are already like maximal consequences for the people around
me. Now not not in terms of reporting and again, Dickers ref-
basically said this is he shouldn't do it. Chudat said it's he
shouldn't do it. Aiden never even saw this [__] to
begin with. He might have some principal agreement with me, but
he never about this at all. So like the other creators around
me don't about this at all. They're not looking to report. They
don't want to anything to do with it. So again, that's fine.
Okay, that's fine. I'm not mad at these people for not wanting
anything to do anything to do with it. I'm mad or I'm annoyed
at the idea that you would go and instead of instead of just
ignoring this, you will go and cover it and do it in a way that
helps the people who are engaging in the like catastrophic behavior
towards the commentary space.
That's what the outcome of your actions is. When you go live
and you know that Dan is a threat to you, that Destiny is a threat
to you and that Qman, me, all these people are not and then you
spend all of your time hand-wringing about our behavior and nothing
on them, the outcome of your action is you help them. All I'm
asking for you to do is to not help them. I'm dealing with it.
Do you know what I mean?
It's like and and it's like I don't want to be corny thing, but
like why why would [clears throat] I want that near me? Why do
I want someone near me >> that can't deal with these things
very
Does that make sense? It's like you're a [__] idiot.
You're a [__] idiot and you're terrible at dealing
with this I've got other [__] to worry about rather
than someone doing stupid [__] And you know, I don't
want that splashing onto me. That's got nothing to do with me.
That's not my [__] lookout, you know? Yeah. I would
I would wonder why he called
I would wonder why he called Nicholas Ybarra at all for his bad
coverage.
What was the point of that? Why Why would he take a stand there?
That had huge negatives for you.
Right? Why did you take a stand there? You cuz what you just
said, oh I just don't want that [__] around me. Oh,
I don't want like any bad Well, if somebody's like if somebody's
basically chilling speech all over the
why in the world would you say, oh well, I don't want anyone
around me. I never want to talk about it.
Outside of or at least why would you say that and then go on
your stream and basically advocate for other people to say that?
Why would you like demoralize the side that's trying to stand
up for some principle or some
higher ideal?
I don't get it. Um They don't volunteer. Well, sure, yeah. I
mean, obviously, you know, I defended Lakandula and [snorts]
Shmee on you know on like a a basis of their credibility.
Which, you know, in hindsight maybe I'd have handled it differently
if I'd known more information, but what can you do? What can
you do? You can't rewind time,
You're saying J Soc you're I'm saying he's saying that J Soc
in in in correct me if I'm wrong Dan, but that this Dan said
we're innocent. Well, let me get to that part. I don't give a
[__] about this. Let me to that >> Uh J Soc
organized mass reporting of other people. >> Step by step.
And I understand that Destiny and J Soc are in a holy war, but
you guys you have standards. You don't do that [__]
No, we we have standards against doxing, Dan. We have standards
against standards against doxing about like intentionally [__]
with other people's communities,
>> So, again, what happened here is Destiny stated that
he was going to people if they didn't stop covering him. Then
he started trying to dox those
Then eventually gets to the point where he starts trying to dox
people in those communities who are commenting on him. Okay?
And he revels in and celebrates the fact that people are leaving
that that community because they've been targeted by him. Okay?
You can say
oh well, you know, you can say to yourself, well, I shouldn't
be involved. But what you can't say is it is wrong to organize
those the people in that community when again there's admitted
stated malice, there's intentional repeat offenses, and it's
an objective self-evident violation. It's not subjective in any
way. You cannot say it's wrong to report that or even to advocate
for others to report that. Because it's not.
It is like the objectively correct thing to do. You just don't
like that it's going to possibly [__] up your money.
Now, the sad thing here or perhaps the saddest thing here is
Chud was not in the Discord. Chud was not connected to this,
and he got reported by people. Right? I've been I was live on
Twitch for 12 hours yesterday covering Destiny.
I didn't get reported like I fine.
So, I don't know. Like he I understand he feels like in danger
or threatened, but that is the whole point is you basically stop
covering the other side of this. You stop talking about the other
side of this.
That's why they're doing it to you. That's why they're they're
they are forcing you to play by rules that are not the rules
they play by. If you want to just let them warp the playing field,
then yeah, go somewhere else, man. Just just don't comment.
You're different. Well, yeah. Okay. Well, he did that. I just
I I didn't actually review this before I went live or I reviewed
a little bit of it, but um most of my commentary was going to
be on the other thing, but I did want to start here cuz it it
feels important to start with this. >> You guys watched
it. You let it go by. So, let me ask you, why should that not
be done to you? In like a Destiny
Okay, but you're you're hanging >> Okay, dude.
>> The problem is it doesn't matter to these people. They
don't care whether or not you've not done something bad from
their perspective. They see it as an eye for an eye. And this
They don't even see as an eye for an eye. He just said something
completely
afactual, completely
They don't see it as an eye for an eye.
They've never seen it as an eye for an They didn't come back
at me or Kweiman or anybody doing this and go, "Oh, we're going
to cover you guys. And we're going to like make jokes about you
guys." They started trying to dox people. They threatened to
dox people. It's not an eye for an eye at all. They're going
insane with their escalations.
And they're trying to chill any criticism of Destiny to abet
crimes. That's what they're trying to do, Chud. And all I'm asking
for you to do is find the spine not to stand with us and and
say that's wrong, not to do what I would say is the right thing.
I just want you to have enough of a spine to shut your stupid
mouth. That's all I want. Just have enough of a spine to go crawl
off into the corner to prostrate yourself. Don't come prostrate
yourself in order to trip
That's all.
That's all I'm asking for, man. >> This is why, even if
you think you're
God, I'm it's it's just awful We keep going. It's awful to do
it with people that are psychotic and we just want to go eye
for an eye at you. Like, why why get into it and talk about it?
You just open yourself This is just the gilded poo position.
Well, actually they doxed me and they they swatted me, but I
would never report somebody. I would never do that. Are you out
of your mind? I understand By the way, I understand not talking
about it. I understand,
I understand not talking about it. I understand wanting to walk
away. I'm totally fine with that. You This is not your fight.
You don't have to stand here and fight. This is not existential
for you. I understand having a
It's just this. It's just this whole thing of like, "Well, actually
they're going an eye for an eye." No, they're not. Never been
an eye for an eye. They're always doing extreme
A chase dog, that's gay. He's just doing By the way, that's what
it's going to be. When Chud says, "Oh, it just looks
Know that in his heart he understands he is gilded poo. That's
why he's got the hat and the beard. He's just gilded poo going,
"This is gay and cringe. This is gay and cringe." You don't have
an argument. You are essentially lying not really to anyone else,
just yourself.
That's all. Self up. For like exactly the same to be done to
Do you see what I mean? And this is the thing is like you know,
people doing this thing with the contros where they're like,
"Yeah, man, go him down. Go him down." What are you Yeah, you're
down. You're getting him. You're getting him. You're getting
him. And it's like this guy has just had a year-long war with
Twitch, right?
What Why you Why you, you know, putting your head in the lion's
mouth?
So, what if they What if they went to that war? By the way, W
Twitch.
What if Twitch just decided to deplatform Hasan cuz they didn't
like that they were losing advertisers?
What if that was the way it worked? Dan almost has enough power
to get Hasan
Dan is openly wanting to do it. What did Hasan do to Dan? Nothing.
They don't need a reason to go after you. And by the way, Chud,
I hope you understand this because maybe you're maybe you're
lying to yourself about this, too. Or maybe I'll help you get
away. But, if I didn't do this stream, if I don't go live and
call you a coward, call you a for doing this,
you did enough. You've done enough. You're already an enemy.
You don't get to walk away.
They're not going to stop reporting you. They're not going to
stop any of this.
Are you serious?
By the way, you immediately came out and knelt right after that
conversation. You knelt and were like, "Oh, I can't believe I
defended a contros. I'm such a Why did I do that? Why did I [screaming]
do that?" And then, what, a day later you go, "Oh, I'm I'm going
to ban Shimmu. I had no idea. I had no idea THAT HE'D DONE ANY
of these things. I'm just Yeah, please, Dan, solve it,
Why did you even walk away from Nick? Why did you say anything
bad about Nick? What was your criticism of Nick? Like, I get
it. I get I totally get it, okay? I get not wanting to start
a fight with them, but just the whole thing where you have to
come back and like hit the people who you're friends with makes
no sense to me whatsoever. Especially when you don't really have
any grounds to make these criticisms on when you've not about
yourself with the facts. Do you see what I mean? It's like just
don't you know, you don't want the smoke. You don't want the
smoke, do you? It's not worth it. Like, what are you gaining
from that interaction? What are you gaining from that fight?
He did nothing to Twitch, no.
But but do you want, you know,
a guy that's that relentless on your case? Probably not, no.
For what benefit? For what upside?
Do you see what I mean? Like
Basically, the benefit of hoping that if something similar happened
to you, you'd have a couple principal people who'd stand shoulder
to shoulder and say that was wrong.
Do you know what I mean? That if you were the person being targeted,
that if you were the person who is the target of some psycho
with a big platform, that you'd have other people who come along
and go, "Hey, that's [__] up. Hey, that's wrong."
I don't like that because that's where we're hurtling towards
really fast. We Have you not been paying attention to the entire
H3 saga where they are using lawsuits under false pretenses to
go after people. Just slap
This is the same tactic but with doxxing and real life harassment
instead, okay? Or the threat of real life harassment.
That's what it is. You understand that your entire way of life,
your whole thing where you critique things, where you you're
a critic on the internet. You are providing commentary. That's
what is at risk. Your way of life is at risk. And I understand
you can just take a knee and go and do your little show and basically
probably run out the clock and never have a problem.
But you you shouldn't handicap or hamstring the people who do
want to take some kind of stand on this, man. That's all I'm
asking. Just don't
Just walk off. >> What what benefit are you getting from
that? What praise from Twitch?
Sounds like chilling effect. I don't think that's chilling effect
It's abs- dude.
I don't think that's chilling effect
old are you right now? I don't think that's chilling effect necessarily.
Um
Are you Are you the most man on planet Earth? Hold on. I didn't
realize I was covering Chud's face. I shouldn't have been covering
it. The most man on planet Earth. Oh, I don't know if there's
like a chilling effect here, guys. What the [__]
are you talking about, >> I'm talking about Nikondros doing
these autism threads. Nikondros was doing giga autism threads
and saying all this crazy [__] about Dan. And yes,
Dan was saying crazy [__] back. It's not about the
chilling effect. It's like, what are you getting from that? What's
the upside? What's the benefit from that? Well, sure. You can
call it a chilling effect. Okay, fine. Fine. Call it a chilling
effect if you want. Yes, fine. Yeah, you are the most dude. Dude,
his entire chat is like, yeah, why doesn't he want to criticize
Dan anymore? Cuz he thinks he's [clears throat] going to get
[__] idiot.
I don't know if like Dan's threats to [__] people
are really creating a chilling effect. Nikondros went silent.
And again, I don't blame him for going silent. That's fine. At
the At the very least, at bare minimum, Nikondros wasn't so much
of a to go and start criticizing anybody else who was criticizing
Dan. By the way, I'm basically taking a knee on criticizing Dan.
I'm I'm mocking Chud for hamstringing the people who were doing
it, who were criticizing Dan or Destiny. But I'm basically taking
a knee on criticizing Dan cuz I'm trying not to get anything
else [__] up, okay? But like, I could just say that.
I don't have to pretend that I'm standing on some kind of principle.
Well, actually, there's like a, you know, what what what do I
gain? No, I'm scared that if I keep like if I keep criticizing
Dan, basically a bunch of other allegations about me are going
to arise that are have totally meritless, totally made up, right?
So, I will take the knee. But at least I can say it.
I don't think Come on. Does You really think there's a chilling
effect? Brother, you just You just said this guy is a schitzo
and he's in a holy war with
You know he's been doxxing people. You know these people around
him have been doxxing people. You talk about that. >> well
I take the hours of chilling effect. Yes, I agree. Yes.
But to me it's like you wouldn't go to war with a kiwi farmer,
would you? A kiwi farmer is not participating in the same marketplace
you are.
A kiwi farmer is not a massive it doesn't have a massive platform
and has not done like the same things worthy of that that level
of criticism, right? What the [__] are you talking
about? Why are you pretending that the whole point of like of
going against these people is they have the resources to harm
a lot of people and the entire platform's speech, right? The
entirety of YouTube speech. That's why people are going after
them. That's why people are criticizing them. What how What is
this false dichotomy, man? This false equivalence.
Dude, this is he's doing like every bad argumentation thing to
get away from like saying I'm just a [__] and I want
to run. You're a [__] you want to run. That's fine.
That's fine. I don't even say it with hate. I get it. I Listen,
if I had
if I had kids, I would do the same thing. If I had people I needed
to take care of that way, I would do the same thing. Would you
have a convo with chat about this? Yes. >> And that's my
perspective on this. It's like, you know, you wouldn't go to
war with a kiwi farms person and that's a chilling effect. But
then the upside is you're not going to end Dude, but I you know,
I don't want to get into the details of I don't want to expose
Does a kiwi farms person have like tens or hundreds of Yeah,
you do want to stop talking about it cuz this is a totally false
equivalence. God.
Who's in I need to stop my follow certain accounts on Twitter
that are close to kiwi farms, right?
And as a result of all of this that's happening there is some
crazy stuff that is happening, okay? That's all I'll say on it.
But like you know, people just get posted. Like you don't want
to be anywhere near this dude. And this is the thing is That's
all you need to dis That's all you need to say. I don't want
to be near
That's all you need to say. I don't want to be near it at all.
It's so easy, man.
I don't want to be near this.
That's all the commentary we need. >> Precisely. I thought
this all seems like a mess like that. Do you see what I
And so I made the decision to obviously not really get into it.
And and yes, you know, I did decide to have the
And I'll, you know, take take responsibility for deciding to
participate in some way. But then, you know, I take a step into
it, two of my channels get you know, a measure against them.
My Discord gets taken down for 12 hours. And that's the least
of it. While other people are getting like full docx man. It's
Hey. Okay.
You This is again You should actually delineate between what's
happening. Like you're just talking about this in a sloppy way.
You're getting like a You're mixing things. That sounds like
people are getting docxed for speaking up against
Right? That at least in the most recent thing, I I've not seen
that happen. Right? Not that it wouldn't or couldn't.
Crazy how that And the thing is it's like it's not even it's
not even necessarily people that are in these different two different
sides. It's like, you know, KF people are sniffing about and
they want to slice of the action as well.
I need people within these two sides. I don't even know what
this means.
I've no idea what this means. >> I mean?
So I just think you're kind of putting a target on your back
if you are participating too much in this. What is
And like scream We'll get near the end of this week.
So Logic was not in the server. While you guys [__]
in DGG and whatnot. Hate the guy, whatever. He wasn't in there.
He was living his principles. Kweiman wasn't there. But when
I looked through I didn't see any crazy [__] from
him. That's not to say his community is not involved, but he
wasn't in there. He wasn't doing any crazy [__] And
in fact, I saw him pushing back. >> Dude, it's just so
crazy to me that like this needs to be said. Like yeah, this
[__] is literally nothing to do with me. And somehow
well there was this effort to kind of implicate me and and drag
me into it, which I participated
I mean, the effort was just to destroy you because everybody
around Destiny hates you and they're going to keep hating you.
Do you think Do you think Stardust is going to hate you any less?
Do you think Not So Aerodate is going to hate you any less? Do
you think these people like you now, Chud? You think they're
going to let this go? You think they're never going to come out
the next time you get in any kind of fight whatsoever and bring
up every single one of these same attacks to go after you with?
What do you think's going to happen?
But don't don't worry about it. Don't think too far in the future.
It's fine. >> I'm going to be wrong.
Um the only the only possible thing you could say is that there's
people from my Discord that participate in that
Yeah, people can join different Discord
Yeah, again, SP, we understand why Chud is a [__]
I just want him to say he's That's why he's a [__]
I don't want him to do this hand-wringing all the time. So, he's
not doing it now. Now, he's like pretty much fine. He wants it
to be clear for people that he's not involved, right? And I'm
doing him a favor. I'm saying you're a spineless
for a good reason, but you're spineless. So, he can be mad about
it. He can be angry at me. He can disagree with me,
right? And I distance him from it. I'm doing him a favor. People
can join different Discord That's not in my control. And I will
ban people if they doxx, obviously. You know, that is something
I'm willing to do cuz I don't want to be near that
But like if people are being mean, harsh
engaging in behavior that I disagree
you know, it's like that's not really my concern. What's What's
that How is that my Like, could you imagine if the shoe was on
the other foot and I was going to Destiny and I was going Destiny,
there's this server, some of your members are in it, you're not
in it, and you probably don't know about what's in there, but
you need to answer for that and you need to tell them you need
to you know, you're involved in this. It's like it would be completely
unreasonable to expect that from Destiny. But yet, it's expected
of me Yeah. Because what the [__] did I do?
I mean, Destiny's basically expecting that of a bunch of other
people now.
You know, it's like the expectation of other people. >> the
standard. They don't have standards. You already This is the
weird thing is he's acting like it's an eye for an eye or that
there's a standard happening here. There's no standard applied.
You didn't have anything to do with it, right? And you still
got reported. You still got with You still are a part of it.
You're getting attacked by a bunch of people who are adjacent,
right? Okay. Anyway, we're going to go to the next segment, which
is this one right here, okay? This is the This is the better
one. This is the more involved
All right? You know, there's a lot of kind of like flying around
by him, but >> He's talking about me here. >> I don't
know, man. I just I just think there are some things he's done
which is just stupid. Like what?
He was saying that after Destiny started doxxing his community,
he was telling people in Discord server to report Yeah. The thing
is even even if you're just strike while you're dead. Strike
while your enemy is being Yes, exactly. That's That's good logic
to go by.
In fact, I'm going to ask Destiny if he needs any help with this
gay manifesto that he's doing.
That's a joke. I got to talk about that. >> any help with
J Talk segment? I can you know, maybe maybe I can give you some
pointers. But um
The mass reporting thing, dude. I just
No, he's It's not even that he's perceived to be a part of it.
It's perceived It will never not be perceived that he's close
to Kweiman. And as long as he's close to Kweiman, he'll be a
part of it, right?
But he wants to He wants to pretend that he's going to get distanced.
He's not
Right? Unless he wants to totally disavow the like somebody he's
incredibly close to, right? I don't care how justified you think
you are. I don't care how justified Why? Why Why would it not
matter? What? Like basically, you have to have You have to have
the gilded poo standard here. So, Chud, if I were to put you
in this situation, you would never call for these reports. You
never ask other people for help with these reports,
If someone was putting your kids at risk, someone was doxxing
you, your new home, right? And then doxxing people in your community,
doxxing mods, uh mods, other streamers, um like fans of yours,
right? Trying to chill and then explicitly like laughing at you
when people leave because they don't want to be doxxed. You would
You would say, "Well, it's actually still wrong to call for anything
to say anything about that. It's It's totally wrong to suggest
that other people might want to report that."
What? How? How could you have that standard? How could you possibly
>> are. Do not advocate for mass reporting even for your
worst enemy. Obviously, if you think someone has broken the rules
and you want to use a platform's reporting tools, that's your
prerogative.
That's up to you.
I was aware of his like totally spineless Nicantros like disavow
a stream or whatever. Oh my god, I can't believe Nicantros did
that. Where he totally like knelt and tried to get out from under
the the boot of DGG. I was aware of that and back then my thinking
was, okay,
I am not going to say anything cuz then we'd have like a fight
and it's like a fight would just not be optimal. Like no more
brother wars were we're literally not doing that right now. But
now it's like this is like day three or four of him doing this
same cocked hand ringing like a
Just shut the [__] up.
You don't have a point. You don't avail yourself of the facts.
You are a
Which again, I would be too if I had kids, okay? But just stop.
Stop pretending. Stop pretending this is like, oh, this is a
really important thing. You sound like gilded poo. He's about
to go I guarantee you he's about to say the same thing. Well,
this just looks kind of weird. Doesn't this look like weird guys?
Doesn't it look like like optically it would look really bad
to do this? Doesn't it look like optically bad? I feel like it's
coming on. I can feel the Nicholas DiOrio
the the I Nicholas DiOrio, I don't have an argument but I don't
want I don't want to take any responsibility right now. So here's
how I'm going to explain this moment. Oh, it's just kind of like
optically bad? But even if you feel like you're justified,
calling of it, you know, you you are you are calling for the
weaponization of reporting systems in order
Wrong. It's only weaponization
means that you are doing something that is outside that you are
trying to fool them somehow. That only you can only really call
it weaponization when it is a subjective standard. If you're
trying to report for hate speech, if you're trying to report
for some slur, right?
If there's some subjective standard required on the person who
gets the report, right? They have to do some subjective evaluation
of it. Then mass reporting is wrong because you're trying to
increase the likelihood that that goes through. This is an objective
standard. This person is objectively doxing and using an adjacent
platform to YouTube to do This is admitted
admitted malice on Destiny's part trying to harm my community
saying he will dox people, making the threats, and then following
through, okay? It's an objective self-evident standard. Like
it has happened. It is out there. He published the information,
right? And it's intentional repeat offenses and the stated intent
to do it further, right? So he's trying to Imagine somebody's
trying to destroy your community. Somebody's trying to destroy
your way of making a living. Right? Is it wrong to report? They
say life ruination. That's what DGGers say. You're trying to
ruin his life. Is Destiny not trying to ruin my life by targeting
my community directly and then laughing as people leave? Hello?
By the way, targeting my community with something outside of
the accepted arena with doxing
and creating the possibility, the risk of real-life harm. That's
what he's doing. That's how he's trying to chill speech. He's
not making a really great
He's just threatening people. Okay. Okay. Okay. So the weaponization
thing I think is totally cocked and wrong. with the trying to
get And by the way, again, I do actually need to restate this.
The reason he's talking about weaponization or trying to pretend
that he has some principle here without looking into it, right?
Is because he doesn't want to just say, "I'm scared of these
people. I don't want anything to do with it." That's all he should
be saying. That should be his entire commentary on this stuff
because instead he's scared to look into it. He's scared to get
involved. He's scared to care. So he's just going to go, "Well,
that looks really weird." and walk away.
That's why he should just say, "I'm scared." and walk away to
begin with.
get an outcome that you want rather than just reporting some
of these things happened wrong. And I don't care who it [__]
is. I don't give a [__] if it's Destiny. I don't
think it was Techtone. I don't care what Why the [__]
would you compare Destiny and Techtone? Are you a
You a [__]
What is the comparison? Why is he doing these false equivalencies?
Well, yeah, even Techtone's like really bad, but I want to report
him.
What has Techtone done that's anywhere near these three facts?
He's admitted stated malice. He's stated his malice. He said,
"I'm going to dox these people." And then he's followed through
and tried to publish information on those people.
Done it multiple times and says he will continue to do it. And
that these are on an objective standard, that the information
is published and it is verifiable. And what is it? Um that it
can be verified by a third party. It's independently verifiable.
What has Techtone done that rises to that standard that he uses
his platform to enable?
There is nothing. There is nothing like that. It's not close.
It's not even a little bit close, right? He's not using it to
try to take down critics.
That's not what's happening, right? And again, this is all to
chill speech and harm critics.
Why do you keep going? You know? No, advocating for mass reporting.
Because you know, you're you're you're trying to weaponize those
tools then. You Those tools are designed that if you see a problem,
you think it's an issue, you file the report.
>> Right? That's how it's supposed to be used. Where does
it say that?
Wouldn't it be like through the platform then? Wouldn't it be
like you can't even like link to it? The act of calling other
people to report it, you are trying to weaponize those systems.
And the other thing, too, is that's that's
How much time has he spent looking into why the reports were
filed? Does he have an idea of why the reports were filed? Cuz
he might think it was just doxing, right? He might think it was
just, "Oh, this guy hates Destiny." I have said multiple times,
this did not happen until we had the additional element of him
targeting the community,
right? And stating that he's doing so to to chill the community,
to destroy the
That There was no reports before that.
Why are we pretending that like I he just didn't look into anything
or he's
obfuscating? I don't know which.
I assume it's cuz if it's if it's intentional, that's
that's false. >> actual criticism of it. >> I'll keep
going. But also, it looks dreadful. Like also optically it's
a Oh my god.
Also, it just looks really bad.
Hey guys, Nick Fuentes here and I just want to tell you that
because I have no argument, I'm going to say this looks really
bad. Guys, this looks so bad. Doesn't it look so bad, guys?
Oh my god. Yeah, totally Chad. It Your actions were responded
to proximately. Yeah, 100%. You had to do something bad for these
people or to these people for them to do something back to you.
Yeah, for sure.
Bro, just let the schizos win. Just appease them. Let the schizos
win. Absolutely. Yeah, totally totally
Then listen, Chad Chad sitting there it's like, "Dude, this uh
this guy had a butter knife. That's a weapon. I didn't want to
take the risk, so I bent over and let him me in the ass." Okay,
that's fine. Listen, I don't mind you running away. Just don't
help the guy, right? Don't try to hold other people down while
he other people, man. That's it. That's all. Without thinking
about it. And then you you like try to stand here and pretend
that it's not just that you're scared. You do this your thing.
I I've seen this like point being made of like, "Well, could
it work in the other direction?" Well, no, they've not done anything
wrong.
Irrelevant. Doesn't matter. It will still be used to justify
mass reporting against you. And whilst you can't really
Okay. But you should say that that's wrong. You should analyze
the facts. That is the entire purpose of giving commentary. Analyze
the facts as they're given to you and say who the good and bad
actors are.
And but you can't do that because you're scared of the actual
bad actors. So you're cucking your own analysis to support them
instead of just shutting the [__] up. >> Stop
that, right? You can't You can't stop that from happening. Like
my [__] is definitely been reported.
I think you are creating a bigger issue for yourself because
undoubtedly if you are calling for it, there will be, you know,
a more
passionate desire to [__] your [__] up.
Do you know what I mean? Okay. Well, I didn't think, you know,
seeing people in my community making people leave, saying you
will dox anybody participating or discussing your lawsuit, which
has been said, that that definitely like wasn't enough, right?
That they have way more things they could do. They have like
so much more they could do to me. Yeah, definitely.
Which by the way, I tried to avoid this part. I tried to avoid
like when I said I would I could do it with Kick. I never did
that and I never called for it like at all. I never made any
concerted effort to call for it
You know what I'm saying? Like I explicitly avoided that because
I didn't want anybody else to get run over by this. Yeah. And
it's like, dude, you know what would have been better? Would
have been a whole bunch of creators who saw what Destiny was
doing and them standing with a spine. But I couldn't get that.
We couldn't get a bunch of people going, "Hey, we're not going
to collab with this guy or talk about this guy. We're going to
just say this guy. We're actually just going to do negative coverage
of him until he stops doing till he presents some evidence for
why he's been doxxing people. I couldn't have that. I couldn't
get people to stand with a spine there. And now I can't even
get people to stand with a spine on, yeah, it was okay to like
call for people to report him. I can't even get people to not
say it was bad to call to report him. It's just I Dude, it's
I it's wild. It's wild. Like obviously I can't predict the future,
but, you know, I mean, I hopefully, fingers crossed, I mean,
obviously I'm still going to play it careful.
But like I think any sort of mass reporting against my stuff,
touch wood, is kind of at least died down a bit. But could you
imagine if there were logs of me advocating for like the reporting,
mass reporting of Destiny? Like it would probably still be happening
now.
Like it probably still be being used against me now.
Have you considered getting some self-control, some impulse control,
not constantly violating the TOS on every platform you inhabit?
Have you thought about that?
Streamed 12 hours yesterday and that's
Right? I've been streaming on Twitch every single stream. I don't
know, I just I feel like probably you could just get some self-control,
too.
I understand that you walked the line, but you constantly like
flagrantly jump over the line, too.
And I like the comedy, but you're not even attempting to really
follow the rules of the platform, so I don't know what to tell
you, man.
Obviously, I hope Chud I hope Chud's channels do well. I really
hope they don't get like anything um like I I do cuz I I do like
his content as much as I think this is a totally position. I
do like his content. I would love his channels to do well.
Hey, man.
So, you're watching me go through your own back if you advocate
for that, even if you feel like you're justified in doing so.
Yeah, again. Just keep saying Just keep disconnecting the context
and justification from the thing so that you can criticize the
thing without looking into the people you're actually scared
This is This is as directly as I can say it, right? If he looks
into the context, he would have to discuss the context and the
actions of the people he's scared of, right?
So, he's just going to call out the response to that context,
to that justification. He's just going to call that out and avoid
the entire context.
And for me, personally, I just think
that particularly is like egregious, cowardly behavior. Personally,
that's that's how I feel about it. It's egregious, cowardly behavior.
It's not an accurate criticism. It's not accurate analysis, and
it is analysis that is explicitly driven by fear.
And I would not have a single criticism if all Chud said was,
"I'm actually really scared of these people and the mass reporting
that they're engaging in." Maybe if leaves that part out cuz
he doesn't want to upset anybody. You don't want to trigger the
schizos. So, maybe you just say, "I'm really scared to cover
this and I'm not going to comment." Right? Then you don't spend
all of your time focusing on the possible wrongdoing of the people
close to you who are actually being harassed, who are actually
concerned for their safety, right?
Then you could just avoid the whole
But instead, we've had like three streams now of this hand-wringing
I don't know. This this is like hand-wringing spineless and I'm
I'm just kind of sick of it. I would like to stop.
If if it could just stop, that'd be
do a balanced analysis.
Look into some of this stuff. Stop being a
unless you want to be the whole
So, two options. Do an actual analysis, figure out the facts,
stop being a or be the and walk off.
Don't do this
Oh, it just looks awfully bad. I couldn't possibly look into
what's really happening here or or give my actual opinion.
Stop doing that.
And walk on.
My god, man.